في المركبة الفضائية
، فتحت فتحة غرفة معادلة الضغط على
الفور داخل غرفة معادلة الضغط نفسها ، حيث
تم الاستحمام بهذا
اللون الأزرق الجميل ، وكان هناك
ضوء ينعكس
عن المحيط أسفل
[الموسيقى
] ورأيت كوكب الأرض
وقدماي فقط تتدليان هناك وأنا  اعتقدت في
نفسي
أنك تعلم أن هذا جميل تمامًا
ولا أصدق أنني هنا
، ثم قلت حسنًا ، لقد حصلنا على عمل جيد
، ثم في هذه المرحلة ،
تبدأ [الموسيقى] المرتبطة بالخروج فعليًا من الباب
بأشهر قبل ذلك
[موسيقى  ]
فهم تصميم
الكوريغرافيا لما سيحدث خلال
فترة ثماني ساعات
ما هي التحديات التقنية
لهذا النشاط المحدد
أنا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
، أنت سفينة خاصة بك
أم أنك تمتلك نظام الأكسجين الخاص بك
قم بتزويد
نظام الاتصال الخاص بك بالطاقة
، ومن الواضح أن لديك جميع الأدوات التي
أحضرتها معك
، فلديك القدرة على رفض الحرارة
التي تتراكم أثناء
عملك داخل بدلة الفضاء ،
لذا  عليك أن تدير كل ذلك نوعًا
ما كمركبتك الفضائية الصغيرة المستقلة الموجودة
هناك
[موسيقى
] ولأننا نستطيع الاعتماد بشكل كبير على
تدريبنا الذي يسمح لنا بعدم
إغراقنا بالأشياء التي لا يمكنك
محاكاتها هنا
على الأرض
شروق الشمس  وغروب الشمس يخطف الأنفاس
في المدار ،
يكون الليل مظلمًا كما يمكن
أن تتخيله
ليس اللون الأسود ، هذا هو
عدم وجود أي لون على الإطلاق
في نهاية سيرنا الفضائي الأول ،
توقفت عن الثقة
لثانية فقط وكان ذلك  أثناء
الليل ونظرت إلى الأسفل
، وكان بإمكاني أن أعلم بالضبط أين
كنت فوق المحيط الهندي
لأنني تمكنت من رؤية الأضواء على
طول الساحل وهو
شعور لا يصدق
حتى أتمكن من رؤية ذلك  خذ ذلك
في
الاعتبار وكن قادرًا على أن تكون في تلك اللحظة